[mwah] Kiss [mwah]
Can I have a kiss Mommy?
[mwah] All right. Bye everybody.
Love you too.
[fast-forwarding tape]
Hey it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day.
I'm at YouTube headquarters here in San Bruno California and we're gonna learn about two things today.
First, last week's video. I gave you some explosive high-speed video
and I asked you to analyze it. A French-speaking guy named Mr DuPont did it, he created a
simulation and you can actually see that the blast waves bounce off the bottle on the inside
and they coalesce to create a region of low pressure, and if you overlay the high-speed
imagery it perfectly matches, and you can see that that's where the low-pressure
is created and that's where you get cavitation. So if you want to see his model and his math,
go look at the link in the description, he actually did all the work, it's amazing. I've been invited to
YouTube headquarters today for You Tube EDU. They have all these great educators
from all over YouTube and they invited me as well. We gonna take a behind-the-scenes tour of what
it's like here at YouTube headquarters, with Brady,
and also we're gonna go introduce you to a lot of really cool people. Alright let's check it out.
(Man speaking in noisy room) So the thing is, I need to check
the number of electrons, that's my fault, I may have typed in the wrong number of electrons.
This is who?
-- I'm Hank.
Who are you?
- Hi I'm Hank.
Never heard of you.
- Aah well.
Yeah. Hank does a video show called SciShow.
(Destin) This.
- Ooh what is that?
This is a shape memory alloy. There you go. Pull.
[ groans]
Okay now we going to bend it. And then, just wad it up.
(Desetin) We've ruined our spring.
- Oh why did you do that?
If we only had another science
Youtuber. Well that's a math one, that's Vihart.
Oop, hey! Check it out! It's Henry, MinutePhysics. If we only had somebody that had like
five channels... Oh! It's Brady!
- Destin! What are you doing here?
- Oh I don't know. Take this matchbook if you would. You know what? There's a grill over there, is it...
- That's amazing. I've never seen anything like it.
[laughs]
- That's incredible! How did you do that?! (sarcastically)
(Destin) There's some things to keep this hot?
Pull that up. Okay.
(Woman) Yeah. I used to work in hotels.
(Destin) Okay there. I need that. Will you hold that?
- I can't believe you actually stole some sterno.
(Destin) So it takes a little bit, but just watch.
[gasps]
- It's alive
- That's witchcraft!
So this is Mike Rugnetta. PBS idea channel. Pretty awesome. Even has the...
Would you say that's a Norm Abrams beard?
- Oh man, you know... Norm Abrams' a little bit...
and I think I would need a hat too.
- Group six but that's your own group.
Hey this is Destin with group 6. We're making a collaboration video before Veritasium.
[laughs]
We're going to a special place with Brady.
[shh]
(Destin) [whispers] This is not happening.
It's against the rules. Can we do it? Are we going?
- Yeah
Okay.
There's a slide at the YouTube office and it's about to happen. This is Angela, and we're about to race.
Angela put on the whole EDU thing, but right now we're just racing.
(Angela) [whispered] I'm totally gonna win.
I don't take stairs I just take the slide.
(Destin) all the time?
- All the time.
- All right are we gonna race or how're we gonna do this?
- Yeah. You go on count?
(Destin) Yeah. 123.
[laughs]
That's her job! That's her job! It's crazy!
- He cheated.
(Destin) Brady you doing it? Do it with a camera.
So we got Logan from TED Ed.
He's going to make some videos soon where you have questions for Smarter Every Day videos.
All that really matters right now is he's about to get beat on a slide.
- This is uncool runnings.
[laughs]
Einz.. Zwei.. Drei..
- Champion.
(Destin) So you can have,
you can have your pet here with you.
- You can have your dog here with you. They even have shuttles
where people get a ride with their dogs to work.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah. So that other people who are allergic don't have to ride with them.
- That's amazing!
- Oh my god it's a [Japanese type of wimpy dog]
(Destin) What are you doing?
[dog barks]
(Brady) I come in peace.
(Destin) There's even a Tiki Bar. Oh man, snacks.
That's nice.
- How's that baby?
That's good, that's really good. Get that out of here! Get! [laughs]
- Actually I stand most of the time. I have a standing desk.
- Why is that? Is it for your abs?
- It's better for you.
- I know. I stand a lot too.
[laughs]
(Destin) I like trinkets on desks.
- You know what? I'll take it.
[laughs]
- You guys are cool with face first right?
- But I have the cards to build the settlement now.
- You're deep in thought Ray.
- I am. Settlers of Catan is intense.
(Destin) Oh, oh.. There we go.
(Vihart) Ok - Again.
Oh nice.
(CGP Grey) I don't think you understand what's happening here.
(Hank) No I don't.
(Grey) No you really don't.
I want two ore or nothing, and you have nothing.
[laughs]
(Grey) Again, this is not my problem.
(Hank) You said "do you have a brick?".
- Okay, big thanks to Angela who put everything on. Howdy.
Thank you so much.
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com